let's talk about the media because the
media of course now is carrying water
for Hunter Biden and we will show you
that they have been doing this for quite
some time here is the most unlikable oh
can we put the uh let's put it up over
there here we go we got it yep there you
go uh we've got the uh most unlikable
person on all of television and that is
not easy this is Sunny Hostin of the
view uh who's a lawyer I've told she's a
lawyer and she's she feels very
confident in what happened here
applicants we'll call them a slap on the
wrist but the but hunter Biden now has a
criminal record yeah and that's what
they wanted right well and it shows that
no one is above the law which is
important not even the president's son
let me ask you this um Jonathan because
this investigation began in 2018. I
remember in 2014 you asking questions
about Hunter Biden and barisma and what
was going on with that and was that
nepotism why are we only seeing charges
five years later and why are these
charges limited to these these cases so
do you see how the machine operates she
can get up there with a straight face
saying no one's against the law because
they're slapping his wrists with
something they're not putting him in
jail for something other people Wesley
Snipes for example would be in jail for
right they cop the plea deal before they
even released any of the information but
then it allows her to go see no one's
Above the Law even the president's son
because it's all a grift and an endless
lie and the problem for these people is
more of us are seeing it every freaking
day
[Music]